playing around with nuclear weapons in
videos is fun there's a visceral joy in
blowing things up and a horrifying
fascination with things like fireballs
shockwaves and radiation
and while it does help put our
destructive power in perspective it's
not the best way of understanding the
real impact of a nuclear explosion
this isn't about city stacks of tnt or
about how bright an explosion is
nuclear weapons are about you
so we've partnered with the red cross
and red crescent movement to explore
what would really happen if a nuclear
weapon were detonated in a major city
today not nuclear war just one explosion
[Music]
we begin our story in the middle of
downtown in a major city people are
going to work studying for exams are
lost in their thoughts and daily lives
right here a nuclear weapon is detonated
and time freezes
the first phase of the explosion happens
within less than a second in a
millisecond a ball of plasma hotter than
the sun appears and grows in a fireball
to more than two kilometers across
within this ball everyone is just gone
think of water dripped onto a very hot
pan
a sizzle and then there's nothing
most buildings cars trees tacky
sculptures and people all evaporated
first the flash an intense tsunami of
light washes over the city in an instant
if you happen to have your head pointed
in the direction of the explosion it
renders you blind for a few hours
the heat of this light produces a
thermal pulse so energetic and hot that
it just burns everything as far as 13
kilometers from the destination site
what this means is that everything in an
area of 500 square kilometers that is
able to burn starts burning
plastic wood fabric hair and skin
if you happen to be in reach of the
thermal pulse one moment you're on your
way to work the next moment you're on
fire
now the second phase begins it happens
in a few seconds
most people will now first notice that
something is wrong but it's already too
late for hundreds of thousands
the flash is followed by the shock wave
the heat and radiation of the fireball
create a bubble of superheated and super
compressed air around it that's now
expanding explosively
faster than the speed of sound creating
winds stronger than hurricanes and
tornadoes
human infrastructure is no match for its
power
most major buildings within a kilometer
of the fireball are just ground up down
to their base
only steel reinforced concrete is able
to partially resist the pressure in the
surrounding parks where retirees feed
the ducks trees blackened and smoldering
from the heat a second before snap like
toothpicks
if you're outside you get tossed away
like a grain of dust in a tornado
the shock wave weakens as it travels
outwards but still about 175 square
kilometers of houses collapse like
they're made of cards trapping tens of
thousands of people who didn't have any
time to react
gas stations explode and fire spread
throughout the rubble a mushroom cloud
made from the remains of the fireball
dust and ash rises kilometers into the
sky in the next few minutes and casts a
dark shadow over the ruined city
this violently pulls in fresh air
surrounding the city destroying more
buildings and providing an abundance of
oxygen
it depends on the city what happens next
if there's enough fuel fires may turn
into a firestorm that burns the rubble
everybody trapped in it and people
trying to flee the devastation
up to 21 kilometers from the explosion
people just like you rushed to their
windows to take pictures of the mushroom
cloud unaware that the shock wave is
still coming at them about to shatter
their windows and create a blizzard of
sharp glass
the third phase begins in the coming
hours and days we're used to the idea
that help will come no matter the
disaster
this time is different a nuclear
explosion is like every natural disaster
at once
there are hundreds of thousands or
millions of people with serious injuries
lacerations broken bones serious burns
in the next few minutes and hours
thousands more will die because of these
injuries
[Music]
countless people are trapped in
collapsed buildings like in earthquakes
or blinded by the flash death from the
blast wave and unable to flee through
streets impossible with rubble and
debris
they're terrified confused and don't
know what's happened to them or why
most likely many hospitals have been
leveled along with all the other
buildings and most medical professionals
are either dead or injured along with
everyone else
the survivors lucky enough to have been
in metro tunnels or standing in the
right place to be unburned and unhurt
won't have truly escaped harm yet
depending on the type of weapon where it
explodes and even the weather an awful
black rain can begin with radioactive
ash and dust descending on the city
covering everything and everyone
the invisible malicious silent horror of
radiation takes its turn
every breath carries poison to the lungs
of the survivors over the coming days
the people who receive the highest doses
of radiation exposure will die
there will be no help not for hours or
maybe even days
civilization doesn't operate when there
is a total breakdown of infrastructure
roads are blocked train tracks warped
runways cluttered with rubble
no water no electricity no communication
no stores to replenish supplies from
help from surrounding cities will have a
hard time entering the disaster zone and
even if they can the radioactive
contamination will make it risky to get
too close
after a nuclear attack you're on your
own
so bit by bit people emerge from the
rubble on foot contaminated with
radioactive fallout carrying what little
they may have left
they are slow in pain traumatized and
they all need food water and medical
treatment fast
and the damage done by a nuclear weapon
doesn't end when the fires burn out and
the smoke clears
the hospitals in the neighboring cities
are under-equipped for a disaster of
this scale and overwhelmed with tens or
hundreds of thousands of patients with
serious injuries in the weeks months and
years to come many of those who survived
will succumb to cancers like leukemia
the reason no government wants you to
think about all this is because there is
no serious humanitarian response
possible to a nuclear explosion there's
no way to really help the immediate
victims of a nuclear attack
this is not a hurricane wildfire or
earthquake or nuclear accident it is all
of these things at once but worse
no nation on earth is prepared to deal
with it
the world has changed in the past few
years with world leaders again
explicitly and publicly threatening each
other with nuclear weapons
many experts think the danger of a
nuclear strike is higher than it has
been in decades
governments tell their citizens that
it's good that we have nuclear weapons
but it's bad when anyone else gets them
that it's somehow necessary to threaten
others with mass destruction to keep us
safe
but does this make you feel safe
it only takes a small group of people
with power to go crazy or rogue a small
misstep or a simple misunderstanding to
unleash a catastrophe of unimaginable
proportions exploding stuff in videos is
fun
exploding things in real life not so
much
there is a solution though
eliminating all nuclear weapons and
vowing never to build them again in 2017
almost two-thirds of all the world's
countries supported by hundreds of civil
society organizations and the
international red cross and red crescent
movement agreed to prohibit and
eliminate nuclear weapons
it's not about who has nuclear weapons
and who doesn't the weapons themselves
are the problem
they are deeply immoral and an
existential threat to all of us
no matter what country you come from no
matter what political side you find
yourself on we need to demand that they
disappear forever
this will not happen without pressure if
you want to be part of this pressure
there are things you personally can do
too
visit notonukes.org to learn more about
nuclear weapons and what you can do
about them
[Music]
[Music]
you